The New York Times reported in January that a rise in the number of suicides among students in Clark County, Nevada, had pushed the school district to reopen its school buildings which had been shuttered since the beginning of the COVID-19 pandemic. 18 students had died by suicide in the Las Vegas area district since March 2020. That report was just one of a number of news articles that have suggested that the pandemic may be raising the risk of suicide as people in the U.S. and around the world cope with the virus and its economic turmoil, closed schools and offices, and other disruptions that have come with it. But even before COVID-19, the suicide rate in the United States had been increasing in recent years, particularly among young people.
《纽约时报》一月份报道称，内华达州克拉克县学生自杀人数的增加，促使该学区重新开放了自新冠疫情爆发以来一直关闭的校舍。自2020年3月以来，拉斯维加斯地区的学区已有18名学生自杀身亡。那篇报道只是众多新闻文章中的一篇，这些文章表明，随着美国乃至全球的人们都在应对病毒及其带来的经济动荡、学校和办公室关闭以及随之而来的其他干扰，疫情可能正在增加自杀风险。但即使在新冠疫情之前，美国的自杀率近年来也一直在上升，尤其是在年轻人中。
What's behind this rise? What can we do about it? What effective interventions have psychologists and other researchers developed to help those at risk of suicide? And what can you do if you're worried about someone in your life? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Jill Harcovy Friedman, the vice president of research for the American
这种增长背后的原因是什么？我们能做些什么？心理学家和其他研究人员开发了哪些有效的干预措施来帮助那些有自杀风险的人？如果你担心生活中的某个人，你能做些什么？欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》，该节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是美国
Foundation for Suicide Prevention, and an associate professor of clinical psychology and psychiatry at Columbia University. She has more than 30 years of experience as a clinician and researcher and has worked to translate research and suicide prevention into clinical practice. Her own research has focused on suicidal behavior among adolescents and adults. She has published more than 100 research articles and was the first researcher to ask high school students about suicidal ideation and behavior. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. Harkaby Friedman. Thank you so much for having me, Kim. So as I mentioned a moment ago in the introduction, before the coronavirus pandemic, the suicide rate
自杀预防基金会研究副总裁、哥伦比亚大学临床心理学和精神病学副教授吉尔·哈科维·弗里德曼博士。她拥有30多年的临床和研究经验，致力于将研究和自杀预防转化为临床实践。她自己的研究重点是青少年和成人的自杀行为。她发表了100多篇研究文章，是第一位询问高中生自杀意念和行为的研究人员。感谢您今天加入我们，哈卡比·弗里德曼博士。非常感谢您的邀请，金。正如我刚才在介绍中提到的，在新冠疫情之前，自杀率
had already been increasing in recent years in the United States. Do researchers have any idea why this might be? You know, that's a great question. What has led to the increase in suicide rates, especially over the past 10 years? The short answer is we don't have a specific answer, but we have some thoughts. And one of the thoughts has been that maybe it's just better reporting because we've become more willing and able to talk about suicide, suicide risk, and so perhaps some deaths that might not have been recognized as a suicide are now being identified as such. So that's one reason. Other than that, the one change that's been shown in the literature is that the rates were actually going down in the 90s, which is, if you recall,
近年来在美国已经呈上升趋势。研究人员是否知道这可能是什么原因？这是一个很好的问题。是什么导致了自杀率的上升，特别是在过去10年里？简短的回答是，我们没有具体的答案，但我们有一些想法。其中一个想法是，这可能只是因为报告情况有所改善，因为我们变得更愿意也更有能力谈论自杀和自杀风险，所以也许一些以前未被认定为自杀的死亡现在被识别出来了。所以这是一个原因。除此之外，文献中显示的一个变化是，90年代的自杀率实际上是在下降的，如果你还记得的话，
that some of the antidepressant medications, the SSRIs, came out in the early 90s, and from that point, from about forward, the rates started going down. Then there were some talk about them actually causing suicidal behavior, and people stopped prescribing them. So there are some researchers that are suggesting and showing that prescription rates have gone down, and at the same time, suicide rates have gone up. So some people explain the rise in that way. There are now, fluctuations in suicide over time. We also in general have better reporting of the statistics. So while we don't really know, those are some of the ideas about it. Do suicide rates in the U.S. vary based on race, gender, or other cultural or demographic factors?
90年代初出现了一些抗抑郁药物，即SSRIs，从那时起，大约从那时开始，自杀率开始下降。后来有一些关于它们实际上会导致自杀行为的讨论，人们停止了开具这些药物。因此，一些研究人员建议并表明处方率已经下降，与此同时，自杀率却上升了。所以有些人以这种方式解释这种增长。现在，自杀率随时间波动。我们总体上也更好地报告了统计数据。所以虽然我们并不真正知道，但这些是关于它的一些想法。美国的自杀率是否因种族、性别或其他文化或人口统计学因素而异？
And if so, which demographic groups are at greater risk? Risk for, I mean, suicidal behavior cuts across all demographics, all social factors. So the way suicide works is that there's not really one cause. So it's not like there are groups that have higher rates, but that doesn't mean that it's causal. So for instance, males have higher rates than females, more than three times the rate. Is there something about being males,
如果是这样，哪些人口群体面临的风险更大？风险，我的意思是，自杀行为跨越了所有人口统计学和社会因素。所以自杀的运作方式是，并没有真正单一的原因。所以并不是说有些群体有更高的比率，但这并不意味着它是因果关系。例如，男性的比率高于女性，是女性比率的三倍多。作为男性有什么特别之处，
or is it that they choose more lethal or have access to more lethal weapons? Or maybe both? Or both. So we don't really know that we know there are differences. We know that whites have much higher rates than other races except American Native American Indian. All the other ethnic and racial groups have much lower rates than those two groups. And suicide is complex. It's a result of many contributors on an individual and environmental, social, biological level, that come together within a person.
还是因为他们选择了更致命的方式或更容易获得致命武器？或者两者兼而有之？或者两者都是。所以我们并不真正知道，我们知道存在差异。我们知道白人的比率远高于其他种族，除了美洲原住民印第安人。所有其他族裔和种族群体的比率都远低于这两个群体。自杀是复杂的。它是个人、环境、社会和生物层面多种因素共同作用于一个人的结果。
and in the context of stress or stressors may increase the risk such as somebody who is already at risk acts on it. And then, of course, you have to have access to lethal means for a person to actually die. So lots of people think about it, a sign of distress. You know, when you're feeling well, you usually don't think of taking your life. Lots of people think about it. Fortunately, way fewer make suicide attempts. unfortunately way fewer die by suicide. Now, what leads, it's not a straight continuum, and that's where some combination of ethnic, racial, and other urban, rural, you know, there are so many factors that differentiate groups.
在压力或压力源的背景下，可能会增加风险，例如已经处于风险中的人采取了行动。当然，一个人要真正死亡，必须能够获得致命手段。所以很多人会想到它，这是一种痛苦的信号。你知道，当你感觉良好时，你通常不会想到结束自己的生命。很多人会想到它。幸运的是，尝试自杀的人要少得多。不幸的是，死于自杀的人要少得多。现在，导致这种情况的，并不是一条直线，这就是为什么种族、族裔以及其他城市、农村等因素的某种组合，你知道，有太多的因素区分了群体。
Whether they contribute is one thing, whether there are differences is another. So there are differential rates, but that doesn't mean that race or gender actually contributes to suicide. Right. It might have complicated it a little bit. No, no, no, that makes perfect sense. So it isn't causal, it's associated. Since the beginning of the COVID-19 pandemic, there have been quite a few anecdotal reports about an increase in suicides, especially among young people. Do we know if the pandemic is having an effect on the suicide rate?
它们是否起作用是一回事，是否存在差异是另一回事。所以存在差异化的比率，但这并不意味着种族或性别实际上导致了自杀。对。这可能让情况变得有点复杂。不，不，不，这完全说得通。所以它不是因果关系，而是相关联的。自新冠疫情开始以来，关于自杀增加的传闻报道相当多，尤其是在年轻人中。我们是否知道疫情是否对自杀率产生了影响？
And if we don't, how long will it take for us to get really reliable data? We don't know yet what the rate of suicide has been during the pandemic in the United States. The most recent formal confirmed statistics that have come out are for 2019. We do have a new system now that collects data from states in a different way, where we know the first quarter of 2020. The CDC just put out a paper, but it's, projected, it's not actual rates, and in their projection of mortality, they're projecting the rate of suicide will go down during the second quarter of 2020. But again, that's based on probabilities,
如果我们不知道，我们需要多长时间才能获得真正可靠的数据？我们还不知道美国在疫情期间的自杀率是多少。最近公布的正式确认统计数据是2019年的。我们现在有一个新的系统，以不同的方式收集各州的数据，我们知道2020年第一季度的情况。美国疾控中心刚刚发布了一份报告，但它是预测性的，不是实际比率，在他们的死亡率预测中，他们预测2020年第二季度的自杀率会下降。但同样，这是基于概率的，
not numbers. It is important to understand, though, that the rates of suicidal ideation have increased, and there are data about young people and the rate of suicidal ideation, depression, anxiety has increased. And so it's important to know that that ideation isn't necessarily going to translate into suicidal behavior. But there may be other behaviors we want to look out for. So we want to take it seriously because trauma, substance use, withdrawal, all those things are also associated with suicidal ideation. And there have been media reports that gun sales have gone up in the U.S. since the beginning of the pandemic. Is this something that we should be worried about? We should always be worried when there are lethal means in a household.
而不是数字。然而，重要的是要理解，自杀意念的比率已经增加，并且有关于年轻人自杀意念、抑郁、焦虑比率增加的数据。因此，重要的是要知道这种意念并不一定会转化为自杀行为。但可能还有其他我们需要注意的行为。所以我们想认真对待它，因为创伤、药物滥用、退缩，所有这些事情也与自杀意念有关。有媒体报道称，自疫情开始以来，美国的枪支销售量有所增加。这是我们应该担心的吗？当家里有致命手段时，我们应该时刻担心。
And, you know, it's not that having a gun or a gun will make somebody kill themselves. It doesn't work that way. It's not that gun owners have any more mental health or suicide risk than anyone else, but they are lethal. So when there's somebody at risk, you always want to try and and limit access to any lethal means that you have in your house. We know that guns are lethal, we know that other things are lethal. By design, I'm not going to list them off because I don't want to give a list of the ways that one can take one's life. But when you worry about somebody, it's important to put some time between the person
而且，你知道，并不是说拥有一把枪或枪支就会让某人自杀。事情不是那样运作的。并不是说枪支拥有者比其他人有更多的心理健康或自杀风险，但它们是致命的。所以当有人处于风险中时，你总是想尝试限制他们在家中可以获得的任何致命手段。我们知道枪支是致命的，我们知道其他东西也是致命的。根据设计，我不会列出它们，因为我不想提供一个人可以结束生命的方式列表。但当你担心某人时，重要的是在人与
and the means they may use. that time allows for the situation to de-escalate, and it also allows for intervention. When a person's in that state, they have very inflexible thinking. So if you block their effort to get a lethal means, they're probably not going to think of something else instead. And even if they do, whatever they pick is going to be less lethal, so they're more likely to survive. Even after decades of study, it seems that we're still not very good at identifying individuals who are at risk of suicide. A meta-analysis a few years ago suggested that most guidelines for recognizing suicide risk factors are not much better than chance at predicting suicide attempts. How big a problem is this?
他们可能使用的手段之间留出一些时间。那段时间允许情况降温，也允许进行干预。当一个人处于那种状态时，他们的思维非常僵化。所以如果你阻止他们获取致命手段的努力，他们可能不会想到其他替代方案。即使他们想到了，他们选择的任何东西也会不那么致命，所以他们更有可能幸存下来。即使经过几十年的研究，似乎我们仍然不太擅长识别有自杀风险的个人。几年前的一项荟萃分析表明，大多数识别自杀风险因素的指南在预测自杀企图方面并不比偶然好多少。这是一个多大的问题？
When you're trying to predict risk on a broad community level or a long-term level, it's really different from trying to. to understand for the person sitting in front of you whether or not they are going to attempt to take their lives in the short term. And that is the challenge. I often, when I'm speaking with clinicians, I ask them, how many of you know somebody who you're worried about them taking their life, but they haven't even talked about it? Literally, everybody raises their hand. And then if you say, how many people talk about it, but you're not worried about them, many people raise their hand. And that is where the risk factors come into play. As clinicians, for instance, or as family members, we need to understand what the risk factors are and the warning
当你试图在广泛的社区层面或长期层面预测风险时，这与试图了解坐在你面前的人是否会在短期内尝试结束生命是非常不同的。这就是挑战所在。我经常在与临床医生交谈时问他们，你们中有多少人认识你担心他们会结束生命，但他们甚至没有谈论过它的人？字面上，每个人都举手了。然后如果你说，有多少人谈论它，但你不担心他们，很多人举手了。这就是风险因素发挥作用的地方。作为临床医生，例如，或者作为家庭成员，我们需要了解风险因素是什么以及警告
signs so it will let us know should we be worried. And because it's different for each individual, that prediction on the individual level is really different than on the group level. So we always say, trust your gut. If you're worried about it, ask. Well, you have to. to do is ask. It's not that somebody may even be at risk in that moment, but start to find out, do they have any risk factors? Have there been any warning signs? And start to have that conversation. One new area of research related to suicide is using digital technology to monitor people who might be at risk. And I know you recently co-authored a paper laying out ethical guidelines for this type of research. Can you talk about that? Yeah. So this type of research is really exciting.
信号，这样它就会让我们知道我们是否应该担心。而且因为每个人都不同，个人层面的预测与群体层面的预测确实不同。所以我们总是说，相信你的直觉。如果你担心，就问。好吧，你必须做的是问。并不是说某人在那一刻可能真的处于风险中，但开始找出他们是否有任何风险因素？是否有任何警告信号？并开始进行那样的对话。与自杀相关的一个新研究领域是利用数字技术来监测可能处于风险中的人。我知道你最近合著了一篇论文，为这类研究制定了道德准则。你能谈谈那个吗？是的。所以这类研究真的很令人兴奋。
because it's giving us the first bird's eye view on suicidal ideation and behavior in real time. And so what this technology does is it monitors people, maybe pops up questions every few hours, and each researcher does it in a different way. It may monitor your what they call geospatial activity, like where are you going? It may monitor your sleep through an actograph, which is what measures your movement during sleep. So there are a lot of aspects related to suicide that it can monitor at the same time. And what we're starting to learn from that research is that some people don't think about, don't think about it, and then they have a crisis, a blip.
因为它让我们第一次实时鸟瞰了自杀意念和行为。所以这项技术所做的是监测人们，可能每隔几个小时弹出问题，每个研究人员的做法都不同。它可能会监测你所谓的地理空间活动，比如你去哪里？它可能会通过活动记录仪监测你的睡眠，这是测量你在睡眠中运动的设备。所以它可以在同一时间监测与自杀相关的许多方面。我们开始从那项研究中了解到的是，有些人不考虑，不考虑它，然后他们经历了一次危机，一个小插曲。
Some people think about it all the time, and their risk goes up at certain times. And some people have this sort of sawtooth up and down, you know, even throughout the day, where they're in a different place about suicide throughout the day. So what we've learned is that there are different patterns of suicidal thinking and behavior and risk, but there are groups of individuals in each pattern, and that's going to help us, right? Just before I just said, it's difficult on an individual level, but if we get a bunch of individuals that are similar, that's when we're going to be able to learn even more about prediction. So the ethical issues that come up have to do with, you're asking somebody in monitoring their risk,
有些人一直考虑它，他们的风险在特定时间会上升。有些人有这种锯齿状的上下波动，你知道，即使在一天中也是如此，他们在一天中对自杀处于不同的位置。所以我们学到的是，存在不同的自杀思维、行为和风险模式，但在每种模式中都有群体，这将帮助我们，对吧？就在刚才我说过，在个人层面很难，但如果我们有一群相似的个人，那就是我们将能够学到更多关于预测的时候。所以出现的道德问题与，你正在询问某人并监测他们的风险有关，
but a lot of times you're not looking at the data 24-7. So how do you decide to set up a study to get the best most accurate data, but also not put the person at risk? And we have learned that the best way to do that is to make a decision and then inform the participants of your decisions. So they know we're not going to be looking at these data. So if you give us a signal that you're at risk, we won't know. So please, here are some emergency numbers.
但很多时候你并没有24-7地查看数据。那么你如何决定建立一项研究以获得最好、最准确的数据，同时又不让参与者处于风险之中？我们已经了解到，最好的方法是做出决定，然后告知参与者你的决定。所以他们知道我们不会查看这些数据。所以如果你给我们一个信号说你处于风险中，我们不会知道。所以请，这里有一些紧急电话号码。
Here's your clinician. Call them if you feel that. Don't rely on us. And then other times they put little messages or they give emergency numbers. So those are ethical decisions that have to be made over the course of the research. What about the reverse? Is there some liability potential for the researcher? So say you weren't watching.
这是你的临床医生。如果你感觉那样，就给他们打电话。不要依赖我们。然后其他时候他们会放一些小信息或者提供紧急电话号码。所以这些是在研究过程中必须做出的道德决定。反过来呢？研究人员是否有某种责任潜力？所以假设你没有在看。
and a signal came across that this person was feeling very suicidal and you weren't there to do something. Does it work both ways? Not really, because first of all, we're studying people who are already at risk for suicide. You know, that's what happens in suicide studies. And sometimes effectiveness means that you've reduced the number of suicide attempts, but you may not have stopped it. Right? So from a researcher standpoint, when you inform the person of what you're going to do, then they don't have an expectation that you're going to intervene.
并且出现了一个信号，表明这个人感觉非常想自杀，而你不在那里做点什么。它是双向的吗？并不是真的，因为首先，我们研究的是已经有自杀风险的人。你知道，这就是自杀研究中发生的事情。有时有效性意味着你减少了自杀企图的数量，但你可能并没有阻止它。对吧？所以从研究人员的角度来看，当你告知那个人你将要做什么时，他们就不会期望你会进行干预。
And so therefore, and you provide safeguards about who they can contact when and where. You give them lots of information. But if you let them know you're not going to be watching it, you're not going to intervene, then they're aware of that, and they shouldn't have that expectation of you. That makes sense. What's the connection between suicide and mental health conditions? Are there particular mental health conditions that are linked to suicide? There are certain, first let's start by saying that what we found from psychological autopsy studies
因此，并且你提供了关于他们何时何地可以联系谁的保障措施。你给了他们很多信息。但如果你让他们知道你不会查看它，你不会干预，那么他们就意识到了这一点，他们就不应该对你有那种期望。这说得通。自杀与心理健康状况之间有什么联系？是否有特定的心理健康状况与自杀有关？有某些，首先让我们从说我们从心理尸检研究中发现的内容开始
and over 30 studies over many, many years, these are not like one study. We've found that when you take a deep dive and you gather information, about 90% of people who die by suicide, have a diagnosable and potentially treatable mental health conditions. So the potentially treatable is the important part of that. However, most people who have mental health conditions don't die by suicide. But a third of people with mental health conditions actually think about it. The conditions that come up are in a single sense, depression, bipolar disorder, psychosis, and substance use. Now, there are many disorders where there's elevated risk because there's comorbid conditions.
以及多年来的30多项研究，这些不是像一项研究。我们发现，当你深入研究并收集信息时，大约90%死于自杀的人患有可诊断且可能可治疗的心理健康状况。所以可能可治疗是其中重要的部分。然而，大多数患有心理健康状况的人并没有死于自杀。但三分之一患有心理健康状况的人确实考虑过它。出现的状况是，单一意义上，抑郁症、双相情感障碍、精神病和药物滥用。现在，有许多疾病存在升高的风险，因为存在共病状况。
And that's something that many times, most of the time we see, where there's more than one mental health problem. So, for instance, with eating disorders, it looks like people with eating disorders are at increased risk. But some of the studies have showed that the risk comes when it's eating disorders with alcohol or substance use or eating disorders with depression, not the group that has eating disorders alone. The same is true for anxiety and for PTSD. So we're looking for comorbidities here. We sometimes see news reports of clusters of people who knew each other dying by suicide. And tragically, this is often the case with young people.
这是很多时候，大多数时候我们看到的情况，即存在不止一个心理健康问题。例如，对于饮食失调，看起来患有饮食失调的人风险增加。但一些研究表明，风险来自于饮食失调伴有酒精或药物滥用，或者饮食失调伴有抑郁症，而不是单纯患有饮食失调的群体。焦虑症和创伤后应激障碍也是如此。所以我们在这里寻找共病。我们有时会看到关于彼此认识的人死于自杀的群体的新闻报道。悲剧的是，这种情况在年轻人中经常发生。
Why does this happen? And is there really such a thing as suicide contagion? There is such a thing as suicide contagion. And interestingly, when you look closer, there's no relationship between the people in a cluster, which is unusual, right? So that's why we worry about the media. It's not going to put somebody at risk who's not at risk already. So in other words, if there's a suicide in a school, it's not going to make somebody
为什么会发生这种情况？真的有自杀传染这种东西吗？确实有自杀传染这种东西。有趣的是，当你仔细观察时，群体中的人之间没有关系，这很不寻常，对吧？所以这就是为什么我们担心媒体。它不会让一个本来没有风险的人处于风险中。换句话说，如果学校里发生了自杀事件，它不会让某人
who's fine suddenly becomes suicidal. However, if someone is at risk, again, because they have a host of risk factors like mental health conditions, substance use, maybe early trauma, head injury, parental separation at a very early age, if they have some of those short-term factors, and they have more immediate factors, like they're in a depression, they're intoxicated, they have just had a major life stressor for kids, it's like failed a test and family breakup and all those things. So for those kids were already at risk when they learn about a suicide, that's where the potential for contagion comes in. We don't totally understand it, whether it's, oh, they did it so I could do it,
本来很好的人突然变得想自杀。然而，如果某人处于风险中，再次强调，因为他们有一系列风险因素，如心理健康状况、药物滥用、早年创伤、头部受伤、极早年的父母分离，如果他们有其中一些短期因素，并且他们有更直接的因素，比如他们处于抑郁状态，他们喝醉了，他们刚刚经历了重大的生活压力源，对于孩子来说，就像考试不及格和家庭破裂以及所有这些事情。所以对于那些本来就处于风险中的孩子，当他们得知自杀事件时，这就是传染潜力出现的地方。我们并不完全理解它，无论是，哦，他们做了，所以我也可以做，
or some interpretation of the results of that person having taken their lives. We really don't know. But what is interesting is that often it's not necessarily the person who knew the person who died by suicide. So think about when famous people die by suicide. Before we were so conscientious in the media, they don't know this person, and yet there could be a rise in suicides. So it also works the other way. Suicide prevention can kind of be contagious, which is when people are engaged in having conversations and helping each other and talking about what's going on instead of bottling it up, that can help prevent suicide. So it works both ways. There are a number of factors that place people at risk for suicide, and one of them is biology.
还是对那个人结束生命的结果的某种解读。我们真的不知道。但有趣的是，通常不一定是认识那个死于自杀的人的人。所以想想当名人死于自杀时。在我们媒体如此谨慎之前，他们不认识这个人，然而自杀人数可能会增加。所以它也以另一种方式运作。自杀预防也可以说是会传染的，即当人们参与对话、互相帮助并谈论正在发生的事情而不是闷在心里时，这可以帮助预防自杀。所以它是双向的。有许多因素使人们处于自杀风险中，其中之一是生物学。
Can you explain the role that biology plays in determining who is at risk of dying by suicide? So when we're talking about the biology of suicide, we're talking about our brain chemicals, our neurotransmitters, we're talking about genetics, and we're even talking about things like inflammation and the gut biome because they're all related. So, you know, the idea of nature, nurture, that debate is over. We've pretty much decided it's all of it. So when there's a biological event, there's also a psychological and social event and vice versa. So let's take one thing, which is your neurotransmitters and your response. So there's been lots of research that has shown that certain neurotransmitters like serotonin are related to suicide.
你能解释一下生物学在决定谁有自杀风险方面所起的作用吗？所以当我们谈论自杀的生物学时，我们谈论的是我们的大脑化学物质、我们的神经递质，我们谈论的是遗传学，我们甚至谈论像炎症和肠道生物群落这样的事情，因为它们都是相关的。所以，你知道，先天与后天的那个辩论已经结束了。我们几乎已经决定它是所有这些因素。所以当有一个生物学事件时，也有一个心理和社会事件，反之亦然。所以让我们拿一件事，也就是你的神经递质和你的反应。所以有很多研究表明，某些神经递质如血清素与自杀有关。
And it's, you know, nothing in suicide is straightforward. So, of course, what happens is that one area of the brain has too much and one area of the brain doesn't have enough. So it's even the balance of those chemicals. And we can only study one chemical at a time. So we don't even know how all the neurotransmitters interact with each other. But we know that there are increases and decreases, particularly in the frontal lobe, which is the executive branch of our thinking, which controls impulse control and a little bit of mood and direction, self-direction, that in that area, there's often a little bit of a lack of activity of certain transmitters. And then in other parts of the brain, there's an increase.
而且，你知道，自杀中没有什么是直截了当的。所以，当然，发生的事情是大脑的一个区域太多了，而大脑的一个区域不够。所以它甚至是那些化学物质的平衡。而且我们一次只能研究一种化学物质。所以我们甚至不知道所有神经递质是如何相互作用的。但我们知道存在增加和减少，特别是在额叶，这是我们思维的执行部门，它控制冲动控制和一点情绪和方向，自我导向，在那个区域，通常缺乏某些递质的活动。然后在大脑的其他部分，有增加。
So it's that balance of transmitters that seems to be different in people who are at risk. And how does that play out? They tend to have rigidity of thinking in the moment. They can't think of alternatives. They get like a tunnel vision. They look at, so kids, now, we're actually funding a study that looks across the lifespan, so we're going to learn more. But we have kids who go for the short-term reward rather than the last-term reward,
所以正是那种递质的平衡在处于风险中的人身上似乎是不同的。这又是如何体现的呢？他们往往在当下有思维僵化。他们想不出替代方案。他们就像有隧道视野。他们看，所以孩子们，现在，我们实际上正在资助一项研究，着眼于整个生命周期，所以我们将学到更多。但我们有孩子为了短期奖励而不是长期奖励，
rather than a long-term reward. So when they're suicidal, they're saying, you know, I feel terrible. I want to do something now. It's never going to get better. Adults, on the other hand, looks like their brain function, says the world is gloomy.
而不是长期奖励。所以当他们想自杀时，他们说，你知道，我感觉糟透了。我想现在做点什么。它永远不会好转。另一方面，成年人，看起来他们的大脑功能说世界是阴暗的。
The world is down. And they have kind of a negative lens. So it's a little bit different in their decision-making. Okay, let me switch to genetics now. That was going to be my next question. Yeah. Like doesn't run in families, for example. It runs in families sometimes.
世界是低落的。他们有一种消极的视角。所以他们在决策方面有点不同。好吧，让我现在转向遗传学。那将是我的下一个问题。是的。比如它在家庭中遗传，例如。它有时在家庭中遗传。
Yeah. Of course. It's what we call a gene environment interaction. So if you have the genetic predisposition, you might have an increased risk for suicide or you might not. So think about something like breast cancer or heart disease, right? You might have the genetic predisposition. So what do you do? You monitor closely and you take action quickly when you start to see.
是的。当然。这就是我们所说的基因环境相互作用。所以如果你有遗传易感性，你可能会增加自杀风险，也可能不会。所以想想像乳腺癌或心脏病这样的事情，对吧？你可能有遗传易感性。那么你做什么？你密切监测，当你开始看到时，迅速采取行动。
signs. It's the same thing with suicide and mental health. You monitor it closely if you know you have family members who have it and let's say you get depression. You treat it early and you treat it with gusto so that it doesn't grow and fester and you get back to your normal, usual self. The longer people are living with mental health condition without treatment, the harder it is to get out of it. So the biology plays a role, but you know what the really cool thing is? That therapies and medications change brain function. So the people who have those problems in the beginning may not have those problems after treatment. So that's one of the things we've learned too, which is so exciting.
迹象。自杀和心理健康也是一样。如果你知道你有患有此病的家庭成员，并且假设你患上了抑郁症，你就密切监测它。你尽早治疗它，并且充满热情地治疗它，这样它就不会生长和溃烂，你就会回到你正常、通常的自我。人们患有心理健康状况而没有治疗的时间越长，就越难摆脱它。所以生物学起作用，但你知道真正酷的事情是什么吗？治疗和药物会改变大脑功能。所以那些一开始有这些问题的人在治疗后可能就不会有这些问题了。所以这也是我们学到的事情之一，这太令人兴奋了。
It's not carved in stone if you have a genetic risk or your brain function is slightly different. and we are talking subtle differences. Treatment helps. Treatment can help you to have a fulfilling life. So if you're concerned that someone in your life may be at risk of suicide, what should you do? What's the best way to approach a conversation with that person? You know, some people are worried that if you actually raise the issue with somebody,
如果你有遗传风险或者你的大脑功能略有不同，它并不是刻在石头上的。而且我们谈论的是细微的差异。治疗有帮助。治疗可以帮助你拥有充实的生活。所以如果你担心你生活中的某个人可能有自杀风险，你应该怎么做？接近那个人的最好方式是什么？你知道，有些人担心如果你真的向某人提出这个问题，
that it's going to give them the idea that they should die by suicide. But is that a valid concern? That's a concern, but it's not valid. I would say that we all worry about that, but the truth is that if they're thinking about suicide, they're already thinking about it. And if they're not, they'll tell you so. So you're not going to make, it doesn't work that way. You're not going to make somebody who isn't at risk, suddenly at risk, or somebody who's suicidal,
这会给他们一个他们应该自杀的想法。但这是一个有效的担忧吗？这是一个担忧，但它不是有效的。我会说我们都担心这一点，但事实是，如果他们在考虑自杀，他们已经在考虑它了。如果他们没有，他们会告诉你。所以你不会制造，它不是那样运作的。你不会让一个没有风险的人突然处于风险中，或者一个想自杀的人，
you're not going to make them have that if they're not already. But there are things that we can do to have a conversation to open up the thinking and the door in the sense of connection so that they can gain a better sense of control over those thoughts. We know connection makes a difference and we know when people are in that state. There's what I call disconnection with a D-Y-S. It's not, it's just a slightly dysfunctional connection. So it's the reason why somebody can say, I love my family and my family loves me, but I'm a burden and they'll be better off without me.
你不会让他们有那个，如果他们本来没有的话。但我们可以做一些事情来进行对话，以打开思维和连接的大门，这样他们就可以更好地控制那些想法。我们知道连接会产生影响，我们知道当人们处于那种状态时。有一种我称之为功能障碍的连接。它不是，它只是一个稍微功能失调的连接。所以这就是为什么某人可以说，我爱我的家人，我的家人也爱我，但我是一个负担，没有我他们会更好。
If you know your family loves you, then you know they're not going to be better off without you, but somehow that logic comes through. And I think that's a good example of how the thinking is shifted. And so when you have a conversation with someone, you don't try to talk them out of it, and please try not to be judgmental because they already feel crummy.
如果你知道你的家人爱你，那么你就知道没有你他们不会更好，但不知何故那种逻辑出现了。我认为这是一个很好的例子，说明思维是如何转变的。所以当你与某人交谈时，不要试图说服他们放弃，请尽量不要评判，因为他们已经感觉很糟糕了。
They are probably in a lot of pain and think the only way they can stop it is to end their life. They're not even most likely thinking about being dead. So when you have a conversation with them and you start that by saying, hey, I notice that you haven't been around lately, like you're pulling back. What's going on? Everything okay? Like you don't start with, are you thinking of killing yourself? You start with. That's an icebreaker. You start with how are you feeling? Are things going?
他们可能处于极大的痛苦中，认为停止它的唯一方法是结束他们的生命。他们很可能甚至没有考虑死亡。所以当你与他们交谈时，你以说，嘿，我注意到你最近没怎么露面，就像你在退缩。怎么了？一切都好吗？就像你不是以，你在考虑自杀吗？开始。你以。那是一个破冰船。你以你感觉如何？事情进展如何？开始。
I know that you've had a lot of stress lately. Can I help? And then you work into, you know, I worry because I care about you that sometimes when people feel like you do or people see what I see, that sometimes people are thinking about killing themselves. And have you thought about that? Because if you have, I'm here to help. I'm not a therapist.
我知道你最近压力很大。我能帮忙吗？然后你进入，你知道，我担心是因为我关心你，有时当人们感觉像你这样或者人们看到我所看到的时，有时人们在考虑自杀。你考虑过吗？因为如果你有，我在这里帮助你。我不是治疗师。
I can't fix it, but I can help you get help. And sometimes people say, no, no, no, I'm fine. And you say, okay, but this is what I see and I'm always here for you, which doesn't mean you're there every minute. Right. It just means that you're going to connect with that. You're available. And they're not a pariah because they feel so terrible. On a broader national level, what kinds of things could lawmakers be doing on this issue?
我无法解决它，但我可以帮助你获得帮助。有时人们说，不，不，不，我很好。你说，好吧，但这正是我所看到的，我永远在这里为你，这并不意味着你每分钟都在那里。对。这只是意味着你将与那个连接。你是可用的。而且他们不是被排斥的人，因为他们感觉太糟糕了。在更广泛的国家层面，立法者可以在这个问题上做些什么？
What are the policy changes you're looking for? There are several policy changes that would make a huge difference in suicide prevention and mental health care in general. So the first is, you know, mental health parity was legalized and enacted, I think it was in 2008, and it is still not fully implemented. So just treating mental health like physical health and having access to care and having coverage. So like if you have access to care, but you have no coverage, it's not going to help you very much because then you're going to have a huge bill on top of everything else. So, you know, if you go into the emergency room with a heart attack, somebody there knows how to deal with a heart attack. But if you go into an emergency room on the verge of taking your life, it's 50-50. I'm just making up the ratio.
你正在寻找什么样的政策变化？有几项政策变化会对自杀预防和心理健康护理产生巨大影响。所以第一是，你知道，心理健康平等在2008年左右被合法化和颁布，我认为是这样，但它仍然没有完全实施。所以就像对待身体健康一样对待心理健康，并获得护理和覆盖。所以就像如果你有护理渠道，但你没有覆盖，它不会对你有太大帮助，因为那样你除了其他一切之外还会有一笔巨额账单。所以，你知道，如果你心脏病发作进入急诊室，那里有人知道如何处理心脏病发作。但如果你在即将结束生命时进入急诊室，那是50-50。我只是编造了这个比例。
I haven't measured it. You know, you might have somebody there who knows what to do. Or you might have somebody who says, okay, have a seat over there, and we're going to try and get a hold of someone who can evaluate you. And a day and a half later, when they ask you again, you're no longer thinking of taking your life. So there are some wonderful experiences and terrible. That has to get equalized. Mental and physical health clinicians need to learn about suicide and suicide prevention, because we have new therapies and techniques that help people. We didn't have that like 20 years ago, so it's no wonder it wasn't enacted.
我没有测量过它。你知道，你可能那里有人知道该怎么做。或者你可能有人说，好吧，在那边坐下，我们将尝试联系可以评估你的人。一天半后，当他们再次问你时，你不再考虑结束你的生命了。所以有一些美妙的经历和糟糕的经历。这必须平等化。心理和身体健康临床医生需要了解自杀和自杀预防，因为我们有帮助人们的新疗法和技术。我们在20年前没有那个，所以难怪它没有被颁布。
I don't blame anybody, but we have it now. So we need to educate our clinical workforce and we need to increase and reimburse our clinical workforce in a way that they will engage in this work. There's a huge shortage of mental health professionals in this country. We need to take care of our veterans. We need to make sure they have action. access to health care. And one of my favorites, since I'm the VP of research, is we need to fund more research in the area of suicide prevention. And guess what? That's not just in mental health.
我不责怪任何人，但我们现在有了。所以我们需要教育我们的临床劳动力，我们需要以他们将参与这项工作的方式增加和报销我们的临床劳动力。这个国家严重缺乏心理健康专业人员。我们需要照顾我们的退伍军人。我们需要确保他们有行动。获得医疗保健。而且我最喜欢的一个，因为我是研究副总裁，是我们需要在自杀预防领域资助更多的研究。而且你猜怎么着？那不仅仅是在心理健康方面。
That's across the health spectrum at a National Institute of Health level, because, you know, suicide and diabetes go together, suicide and heart disease goes together, suicide and physical disabilities go together. You know, it's not like, oh, it's, you know, we all, have brains, we all have social environment, you know, so it's not just in the mental health section. So we need more funding for research. That's where the treatments have come from. And if all that money were available, what are some of the biggest challenges in researching suicide right now? I was, you know, I've been in this field of researching for over 35 years when nobody talked about suicide and nobody would let you ask.
那是在国家卫生研究院层面的整个健康谱系中，因为，你知道，自杀和糖尿病在一起，自杀和心脏病在一起，自杀和身体残疾在一起。你知道，这不像，哦，它是，你知道，我们所有人，都有大脑，我们所有人都有社会环境，你知道，所以它不仅仅是在心理健康部分。所以我们需要更多的研究资金。这就是治疗方法来源的地方。如果所有这些钱都可用，现在研究自杀面临的最大挑战是什么？我，你知道，我在这个研究领域已经超过35年了，当时没有人谈论自杀，没有人会让你问。
So I think we've come a long way. And I'd like to see us continue to keep growing, having access, not being afraid to study suicidal and suicidal people, opening those doors so that people can be studied. You know, a lot of clinical trials, for instance, for new medicines, they eliminate people who've ever thought about suicide. It has nothing to do with if they're in immediate risk. So we're working to help educate people about how to do research with people who are at risk for suicide.
所以我认为我们已经走了很长一段路。我希望看到我们继续保持增长，拥有渠道，不害怕研究自杀和想自杀的人，打开那些门，以便人们可以被研究。你知道，很多临床试验，例如新药，他们消除了曾经考虑过自杀的人。这与他们是否处于直接风险中无关。所以我们正在努力帮助教育人们如何与有自杀风险的人进行研究。
Again, if 30% of people with mental health conditions, at least think about suicide and have that distress, when you eliminate them, what are you studying? And who are you really, who's your target for the medication? So one is just including people who have suicide risk in research. and other barriers, you know, just instrumentation, whether it's that some sites have access to imaging techniques and genetic techniques and other research sites don't, or, you know, because suicide is complex,
同样，如果30%患有心理健康状况的人，至少考虑过自杀并有那种痛苦，当你消除他们时，你在研究什么？你真正的目标是谁，谁是药物的目标？所以一个是仅仅包括有自杀风险的人在研究中。其他障碍，你知道，只是仪器，无论是某些站点有权使用成像技术和遗传技术，而其他研究站点没有，或者，你知道，因为自杀是复杂的，
looking at all the factors related to suicide and not just one. So those are some having the infrastructure to carry on large-scale studies, having refrigerators for genetics, for storing blood. You know, those refrigerators are about $100,000 a piece. So infrastructure is a big problem. But I don't see anything that's insurmountable, and I see that as our technology improves, our ability to study it gets better.
着眼于与自杀相关的所有因素，而不仅仅是一个。所以这些是一些拥有进行大规模研究的基础设施，拥有用于遗传学的冰箱，用于储存血液。你知道，那些冰箱每个大约10万美元。所以基础设施是一个大问题。但我没有看到任何不可逾越的东西，我看到随着我们技术的进步，我们研究它的能力变得更好。
So we need that investment in new technologies as well. Well, this has been really interesting. I appreciate your thinking. and helpful advice that you have put out there, Dr. Harkaby-Friedman. Thank you for joining me. Oh, thank you so much for having me and this topic. And if you're thinking about suicide or you know someone who is exhibiting warning signs of suicide, contact the National Suicide Prevention Lifeline at 1-800-273 Talk. That's also 1-800-273-8255. This is a free 24-7 service that can provide suicidal people or those around them with support information or local resources.
所以我们也需要对新技术进行投资。好吧，这真的很有趣。我很欣赏你的想法。以及你提出的有益建议，哈卡比-弗里德曼博士。感谢你加入我。哦，非常感谢你邀请我谈论这个话题。如果你正在考虑自杀或者你认识的人表现出自杀的警告信号，请联系国家自杀预防生命线，电话1-800-273 Talk。也就是1-800-273-8255。这是一个免费的24-7服务，可以为想自杀的人或他们周围的人提供支持信息或当地资源。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.combeatingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condayan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在我们的网站www.combeatingof Psychology.org上找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目，或者在Apple、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到。如果你有对未来播客的评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件给我们，地址是speaking of psychology at APA.org。那是Speaking of Psychology，全部一个词，在APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·温纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康达扬。感谢您的收听。代表美国心理学会，我是金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。